from kisses to farewells there are a few
scenes that didn't make the final cut of
Starship Troopers
in the world of Starship Troopers it's
only the jock-like Meatheads who end up
on the front lines of The Intergalactic
war between humankind and the alien bugs
who threaten their existence as members
of the mobile infantry they're the first
to die as they fight tooth and nailter
in their citizenship and fair treatment
in Federation space while the Smart Ones
become violets in the psychics join
military intelligence Johnny Rico Falls
quickly into the Infantry and it's
obvious why the theatrical cut makes it
clear that jocks Are Better Built for
the Infantry and thus Johnny is an
obvious candidate alongside his sporting
friends dizzy and apes but a deleted
scene called High School lawn goes a
step further implying that academics are
Johnny strong suit after Johnny does
poorly on a math exam he confides in his
girlfriend Carmen who tells him that she
likes him despite his intellectual
limitations as the two kiss Johnny asks
why she refuses to make love to him to
which she replies that she's waiting for
the right time this scene was only asked
at the very end of post-production but
it would have played within the first 15
minutes to help establish the romance
between Johnny and Carmen the love
affair between Johnny and Garmin is
tumultuous at best at the height of
their romance they dream of a future
together before enlisting in the
Federation tragically it didn't take
long before Carmen breaks Johnny's heart
deeming the distance and their differing
career paths is too much to handle but
before they ever enlist their High
School sweethearts with some serious
Shakespearean parental issues in a quick
deleted scene deemed transporter Johnny
attempts to convince Carmen to let him
go home with her after the semester but
she swiftly shuts him down though it
doesn't last long this moment gives us
some extra context regarding the
Apparently forbidden nature of the
relationship it's revealed that Carmen's
family dislikes the Ricos for not being
Federation citizens though Johnny's
parents are wealthy and ultimately have
no need for service or citizenship their
status as non-citizens is enough for
Carmen's parents to look down on him had
this moment been included in the film it
would have no doubt contributed to
Johnny's decision to join the mobile
infantry as it stands he already enlists
to impress Carmen and eventually earn
his own citizenship so the added
pressure of further impressing her
parents might have elaborated on his
increasingly complicated motivations
you're the reason why I signed up or
Denise is the reason why
one of the best scenes in all of
Starship Troopers is the iconic
klindothu drop which is the first time
we really lay eyes on the arachnids who
threaten Humanity's survival in all the
increase in chaos Johnny Rico is trapped
only to be rescued by his former High
School teacher who inducts him into the
Roughnecks since the invasion is a
disaster the Federation mistakenly
reports Johnny among the ever-growing
list of casualties which devastates
Carmen from afar though she had already
broken his heart Carmen is still in love
with Johnny and she struggles with that
reality in a deleted scene named Xander
consoles Carmen preying upon her
vulnerable state her Superior Xander
enters her quarters to console her only
to creepily confess that he's actually
in love with her rather than reject his
off-putting advances Carmen kisses
Xander and the scene ends implying that
they sleep together
after Carmen and Xander saved the
Roughnecks from an arachnid horde on the
mysterious bug world of Planet P they
take the crew aboard where Carmen learns
that Johnny is alive however tragedy has
struck the young Johnny once again as
his lover and former classmate dizzy
didn't make it out alive naturally a
funeral service is held in Disney's
honor with their old high school buddy
turned Military Intelligence officer
Carl Jenkins in attendance in a scene
called Carmen's cabin which is set
before the memorial Carmen prepares for
the funeral as Xander interrupts her
with irritating questions that quickly
get more personal instead of offering
his condolences for her lost classmate
Xander badges her about her relationship
with Johnny who is not as dead as she
had previously thought offering little
in response Carmen is unsure of how she
feels about the Infantry man but seems
to have reignited the torch that Johnny
previously held for her like the
previous scene all this moment does is
make Xander look more and more like a
creep his insecure prodding and
frustrating presence make us hate him
all the more to the point where we
couldn't care less when his brain is
eaten by the brain bug this scene also
adds very little to Carmen's Arc other
than her apparently rejuvenated interest
in Johnny isn't that hilarious during
the Final Act Johnny and Garmin are
reunited after Johnny gets a strange
urge to travel beneath Planet P's
surface while the battle between the
Federation and the bugs rages Outdoors
down below he stumbles upon a bug
stronghold where the brain bug has
killed Xander with Carmen next on the
menu Johnny Ace and Watkins arrive just
in time to save her and blow the cave to
Smithereens though Watkins doesn't make
it the others live to see another day in
the final moments of Starship Troopers
the brain bug is captured and Carl
reveals that the creature is afraid
having won the battle Carmen remarks
that all might be fine in the end in an
extended version of the same scene
called Last Kiss Carmen lays a friendly
one on Carl soon after she and Johnny
share a final romantic moment themselves
where they also kiss picking up where
they left off though this is a nice note
to end on given their tortured Romance
the removal of this Blissful moment is
almost necessary Not only would the
rekindling of the romance feel a bit
cliche but their decision to remain
close friends reflects how much they've
both grown and that they understand and
respect the other's choices moving
forward
beyond the officially released deleted
scenes there exists another cut of
Starship Troopers one mentioned scarcely
online with only a few photos to prove
its existence this work print was as
close to the Final Cut of the film as
Paul verhoven got before switching
things up for the theatrical release
this version includes nearly every
deleted scene with the only exception
being the transporter sequence near the
beginning with the run time not much
longer than the 2 hours and 9 Minutes of
the theatrical the work print added just
shy of 10 minutes of additional content
total apart from the aforementioned
deleted scenes one notable addition
includes a brief Peak at Xander who
stumbles in the background behind Carmen
as she talks with Johnny over video call
though they aren't a romantic item it
foreshadows Carmen's eventual fling with
her co-pilot which only causes Johnny
more pain along with some added battle
shots that lengthen the war Neil Patrick
Harris gets a few more moments of screen
time including a line where Carl
mentions that it's good to see Johnny
and Carmen again after all this time
evidently test audiences weren't crazy
about the love triangle and after the
removal of all those scenes other Clips
reacts soon after
foreign
[Music]